excusez un terrier toi hein
c'est la terre sur la truffe la
haye ce parti quelque chose
de retaligent entre
de lui une naissance
[Musique]
c'est le regard de l'autre
ivey pas la
tacc
bomba plutôt sympa
[Musique]
oh
la technique
ici high res te prendre dans la gueule
voilà
attentats bouge pas
moustapha
[Musique]
c'est quoi
voici you make
way meilleur ami
[Musique]
alors alex à mort
et
six auteurs après la vis aux partis sont
des jouets
aux
offensives nfl sont pas si grave que ça
ouais bon en fait la personne
pas mal
ouais j'ai trouvé ça la sénatrice aurait
peut-être fait de bois de cet outil deux
arrêts
batterie d'outils rare mais pas sur
scène ouais
ça l'à beaucoup
j'ai tout en couleurs une scie à bastos
et l'a6
à merde ça bouge
ça bouge pas quand vous voulez mais chez
eux
si je suis sur
le cul dauphin ah bah ouais c'est pour
ça qu'il est lourd comme ça aussi les
doutes et parce que ça faisait comme un
câble mais
oui
mais pourtant regarde en voilà et du
blanc
ça montre une voiture ton direct
là je suis bien et monte
ça monte ça redescend nouveau
je vais lâcher
tu fais
ça ressemble un coffre fort
c'est un coffre fort c'est un coffre
fort les gars
100% c'est un coffre-fort ben pas 100%
mais 97 attends attends popol
là on va être gênés par le bon
il faut pas l'ex lâché je pense
c'est un compliment c'est moi un certain
coop ouais
ouais un peu
c'est dommage
je retiens ouverte
en
tout cas les manitobains distributeurs
de préservatifs oh
je suis mort
[Musique]
doit rester peut-être des sens si on met
sa grosse avarie dans le décor
j'ai failli
images et le parisien
attend mais je me suis coincé
attends je vais tomber dans l'oise
ouais pardon
mais au cas là bas
1 2 3
ah ouais c'est énorme oui c'est génial
on va le fouiller
306 génial attendait non regarde et
attend alors c'est quoi ça ah là là
c'est de la balle ronde mais je crois
qu'ils regardent portant sur les doigts
mais contient pas d'argent la nuit a
marqué dessus mais bon si l'envolée de
wilcox
crois que c'était un gang de revendeurs
de capotes nouveaux gangs
n'ont pris le distributeur a c'était on
est sur la route de la jonquera donc
c'est peut-être pour ça et oui
c'est dommage même pas
[Musique]
ouais
ouais c'est quand même super drôle oui
je me remets pas parce que je
m'attendais à voir quand j'ai vu de
l'autre côté mais c'est un coffre fort
alors oui c'est un peu fort tissu on
avait fait un distributeur de chips
pringles regarde l'image elle paraît
très vieille oui c'est ça l'a clairement
ça fait limite années 70 se
dit front ouest en
série supérieure c'est super
la fusée est content que les bougies
c'est leur lame de scie sauteuse la dent
de scie sauteuse forêt
autour de nos portes c'est pas mal
regardez donc c'est un endroit où on a
déjà débloqué des aimants une fois
il semblerait que cet endroit soit
maudit et que les personnes soient
donnés rendez vous pour venir tester la
passion des mots ici c'est un des pires
spot pour faire de la pêche à leyment
voilà voilà des gens regardent
et c'est marrant parce que du coup ils
ont coincé ailleurs n'ont pas quoi c'est
là dessus c'était là dessus voilà c'est
un peu de changements
bah on va essayer de tirer à trois sinon
on sortira le treuil et sinon on ira
peut-être se baigner la personne était
seul allez on a assez parlé on a assez
fait les malins maintenant faut le
sortir parce qu'avec tout ce qu'on a dit
on
n'a peut-être pas abandonner sur les
moyens
ça
va faire du bien
je
faisais pas le malin
se trouve ça trouve il ya 300 milliards
trois cent mètres de corde jusqu'à
l'autre côté
qu'est ce que c'est que ce truc
en plus des années 2000 c'est les avants
qui dans les airs et les américains qui
font sous les ponts ça non
ça donne envie relancer
du coup on vous le rend si vous vous le
réclamer
on va vous demander l'endroit par contre
bien sûr et pas de l'endroit
l'endroit est l'endroit la corde et le
modèle des mains les 50 euros ça c'est
pour l'ukraine n'est pas là le
déplacement ouais ouais
mieux aller vomir bon alors
et à manger une connerie encore
dans nos têtes enlever ça et
bien oui parce que pendant le raid
donc par l'anc rasta règle ses problèmes
de digestion puisqu'on fait ce qu'on va
vous dire à la semaine prochaine pour
une nouvelle idée de pêche aliments ciao
ciao